dramatische Szenen haben sich 4 am Abend
gab ein Klacks schon
vom Süden her kamen ein Mann diese
Treppe hoch
und Prozent
er sprach Englisch Prozent wachsen nicht
abrupt
dreckig feucht Prozent und sagte
ein Jurist kidnappt zwei Männer ist
Darius Schock auf
und Prozent wenn man dann im Internet
Nachwuchs selber der Tat sich seit dem
24 Mai
vermisste es scheint also wirklich dass
Irene könnte Ort ist ein
Entführungsopfer
in der Nacht aufgetaucht ist um es gibt
drei Zeugen und die befragt
wir sind jetzt hier
da wo ihr gesessen habe was ist passiert
enthalten SID
als erste
ran
gleichzeitig reichten 1 die letzten
Einheiten verlangen
Marie marchand-arvier
je weiter die Zeit dränge
bis 30
das gab der Mann gesehen werden
abgesehen hatten
Bonn
wer in Japan hat der DAX seit Wochen
hält
die Hälfte
St
ja und Nein
wir halten würden
ich habe noch einen weiten Weg vor sich
ja sehr
Nein
Buchtipp zeigen
was hat er denn gesagt
Jacobi die Polizeihoheit ein betrunkener
sein können
mehr Prozent
das sagt Prof
erwartet wird dass er
entführt worden wäre
Schieber konnte einem 80 werden
aber eigentlich auch recht schnell
Nettetal
zugegeben habe
fertig los
sie warfen Zustand war er
WM
UL
so also ich bekomme erledigt erklärt
Prozent ich die Tenne aber eingestellt
nls gar nicht Bild rtr wieder war die
Polizei da gemacht
b
erstmal hat ein Prozent
1 China ist
rtr
das erweist er erlitt
jetzt erst recht
das heißt die haben erstmal gedacht
dass ein betrunkener
die wir dann gemeinsam an einen Tisch
bekommen oder ein
ich habe ich Angst haben
weil der leichter
aber wie gesagt der dann darauf gekommen
dass es doch ein betrunkener
hat
rtr
zuletzt kam die Polizei wieder die
richtige hat durch erfasste Stunde
befragt
erstmal will
die Idee vom seit 7
alles Verizon
Miyagi
mal so hoch wie noch nie
Zale 3 1
Wuppertal jeder muss für die Geschichte
komplett getrennt
welcher Wert ersetzt werden
diese Bereiche werden
was glaubt ihr denn er war ab der den
Eindruck das stimmt und was nicht oder
ist es mehr Entführungen oder
aber das ist euer
nicht
wann
sind
der Dienst war
wir investieren
bisher nicht
mehr so erhalten
tanzen lassen
passiert sein
und wer meint Jahres hingelegt
sie kannte
verwirrend Stang
sie zerbrach
ein ausgegangen ist
bei einem Experten in dem statt selbst
der Tat
sichtbar sind
Werder Bremen an
übrigens so sieht er aus
um nach Angaben der drei Zeugen Prozent
während der Tage Bart oder eben etwas
länger
der Gips tragen
auch ein Indiz dass wieder in Richtung
Entführung spricht
ja wenn
alle Informationen Stimmen
dann müsste er von seinen Treffer
meinte ich nen führen genau an diesem
Ort abgesetzt Prozent worden sein
Informationen der Polizei sind im Moment
dahingehend dass er gesagt hat ich bin
mit dem Auto hin gebracht worden Prozent
es ist passt nicht alles Prozent
100-prozentig zusammen aber es ist
schwer Moment zu klären er liegt im
Krankenhaus ist nicht ansprechbar er
steht unter
oben Kabasi unter welchen Blutprobe ist
gemacht worden aber es dauerte zwei drei
Tage Elvis war das Ergebnis vorliegt
also alle traten noch etwas im Dunkeln
dies ist eine Entschädigung rung
schnell steckt und was anderes dahinter
das ist im Moment noch unklar wir
bleiben dran und Prozentpunkten das war
Folter die Informationen zusammentragen